[Music]
Shara is a really interesting figure for
reasons that we talked about and she's
she's still alive as it is his wife and
she lives now on Washington but I guess
you could you know in a way she you
could say she's at least a titular
Midwestern egg so she was born in st.
Louis so let's let's talk about her
biography and then we'll do the
world-building sheet she does a lot of
world building stuff and then I have
some philosophical themes picked out as
usual she is you know in her 70s born in
1942 her last name that originally is
cherry and she was going to change that
in part because I guess she thought it
was it sounded a little bit too silly
for a science fiction author to be taken
seriously that's the story told and I
don't have it in here but they she's
born in st. Elizabeth's they end up in
Oklahoma and that's where she grows up
she has a younger brother who is
considerably younger than her who also
was quite interested in science fiction
and writing and she you know she was
reading comic books and then her father
gives her a copy of Tarzan so she's
reading the sort of stuff that that many
of the other figures that we've talked
about worth into as well and then
something funny happens her family gets
a television set they start watching TV
and Flash Gordon what she's really
getting into gets cancelled so she
decides that she's gonna start writing
herself at ten years old and they they
asked her in one interview how often did
you write every day you know and there
was why were you doing this well I
thought that I would since I couldn't
get the stuff that I wanted I would just
create my
that's kind of an interesting prospect I
think a lot of us would have you know
said well I don't know if I'm up to that
but apparently she thought that that
would be quite fine and when she was 10
her mother heard her say that she wanted
to become a writer and told her you need
to think about something that you can do
so that you'll eat you know so she
started thinking already at that point
how do writers get paid and she was
researching it a little bit finding out
that many of them don't get paid quite
well and so she settled on a career
which really worked out as well in many
respects one way that you can live you
could say the life of the mine that
leads to some some you know degree and
get paid to do something that's kind of
like right he was teaching right so she
decided well I'll become a teacher and
she goes to the University of Oklahoma
and she enrolls there and she she
studies Latin that's that's officially
what she's gonna to get a degree in but
she also you know dabbles or more than
dabbles actually she engages in some
study of archaeology of mythology
history of engineering and she graduates
from there Phi Beta Kappa and then gets
this really prestigious fellowship to go
to john hopkins and within a year she
graduates with her master's in classics
when she begins teaching Latin and
ancient history and a few other subjects
as well for this school in Oklahoma City
where her brother had gone to and she
does that for quite a long time now
while that's happening she is writing
manuscripts and as opposed to a lot of
the people that we've looked at where
they begin by first writing short
stories which then build into larger
unit
versus that they can you know do
remember the fix-ups where you take a
couple short stories and make a book out
of it like a van Voight was a master at
doing that she starts to writing whole
novels but she's been writing this this
entire time anyway and she sends them
out you know place after place after
place and gets lots and lots of
rejection slips doesn't doesn't do you
know quite that well with it but that
eventually gets trashed with this
publishing house where a lot of her
books would come out over the years da w
and it has to do with developing yeah
there you go with with she develops a
connection with one of the editors who
returns her manuscript and says it's too
long and we're looking for something
different so she she she said fine I'll
write something that'll fit that that
bill and she writes Kate of Israel and
actually I only put a you know on the
biographical timeline I only put the
things that fit into the Alliance Union
universe she's actually published over
sixty novels and that's not including
collections of short stories other
collaborative projects that she joined
in on you know other people would create
a fictional world and then they would
say hey who wants to write some stories
for this she jumped in on a lot of those
things she also edited a number of works
as well so these are just the the ones
that fit in with the Alliance Union
universe in some way or another and she
starts you know publishing quite quite a
few of these
she also wins a number of awards I just
have a few of them in there some of the
early ones she gets a best new writer
award and at that point she says okay I
probably can stop teaching
and she's you know making enough money
doing that and then wins a Hugo Award
for Best Short story she becomes an
artist in residence for a while and
another Oklahoma University and then
late a little bit later she receives the
Hugo for for this one big thing you know
home very dense and this is probably is
a great entry point I'd say into the
whole Alliance Union universe once and
it's one of the older ones so that's
that's why I picked down below station
that wasn't actually the first one that
I read by her I read things out of order
the way I think a lot of us often do I
read heavy time before I read the the
other ones but it turns out that heavy
time actually in the universe takes
place before the station so so that
works out okay and then you know she she
actually no she's she's a writing and
writing and writing and some of her
works start getting adapted she meets
the woman who much later on once once
it's legal becomes her wife Jane Suzanne
Fancher and in their connection
originally happens because Fancher is
not actually a writer she is working in
graphics and her
Cera's books are being adapted some of
them for graphic novels you know back
then would they have called it yeah I
guess 85 they would have called it a
graphic novel by then and they start
working together collaboratively and
eventually after a few years
charis starts saying you should start
doing some writing of your own and gives
her some advice about it it's kind of
funny because the story goes that at
first Jane asked her well how do you
write you know how do you get these the
the creative juices flowing and get
things going and so chair gives her some
advice and then she fights you can't
turn
and she's how do you stop writing how do
you turn off all this this creative
stuff and you know she keeps on
developing further aspects of this
Alliance Union universe
she wins another Hugo Award for for
another novel you think this one is his
thick side teen is about twice the
length of this one it's actually a bunch
of different things wrapped up in one
thing and a couple other things that are
kind of cool about her story she has an
asteroid named after her and it's
particularly fitting because you know
she probably more than any other author
that I've encountered really gives you a
sense through her novels of what it
would be like to be out there mining
asteroids just the way she describes
everything and so this is a good entry
to talking up a little bit about her her
approach and her world building she
develops let's put it to you this way
she develops worlds in in the sense of a
narrative universe that are incredibly
dense and very researched but also very
imaginative when I think if I had read
her stuff when I was much younger I
probably would not have been able to
appreciate it
I probably would have given up about 50
pages in because there's so much
descriptive detail about just you know
what docking a a spaceship into a space
station might entail or about these what
it's like to run a particular
bureaucratic operation there's all of
this stuff that
really tells us a lot about the world
she's put you know immense effort and
thought into making this stuff real but
it but it is kind of like there there's
a description of one sci-fi game that a
lot of people would start playing and
then quit playing and the joke was it
was spreadsheets in space that was in
the name of the game it was Masters of
Orion but the the idea was there's just
too much like having to keep track of
details and things like that it's sort
of like you know when we talk about
george RR martin and who the hell are
all these characters and what are they
doing here she's doing that but she's
doing it in a technological age where
mankind has made it out into the stars
and there's very few margins of error
for most people so in the introduction
to gate of everal or the forward to it
rather somebody else who we've you know
read 100 norton talks about chera as
being similar to Tolkien in that you
know Tolkien created an entire languages
and then populated this world and has
this long backstory one of the handouts
that I gave you is actually sort of a
timeline of all the things that are
going on it is universal and this is a
very truncated timeline just drawn from
the first few books and chera was doing
something similar it not so much for
these books which are probably primarily
can certainly you know the human race
but the ones where she has alien species
playing a major role they play a small
role in this but the ones where they're
playing a major role she comes up with
the entire social organization and back
history and sometimes actually languages
and cultures for these these different
and she thinks about how would they live
you know some of them are methane
breathers how do they how does their
respiration work so she puts a ton of
work into that and even for the ones
that are
Merilee just about human beings there's
an awful lot of this as well that was
actually one of the themes that I'd like
to explore in a bit but so let's talk
about what that world or that universe
rather is like so it happens in our
galaxy but it actually happens fairly
close you know much of it happens within
the ambit of the earth and soul you know
our solar system and then these stars
that are a little bit further out
because in the beginning of the
storyline there's nothing like
faster-than-light Drive so how do we get
out to the stars and you notice with
this timeline that we're a little bit
we're a little bit behind schedule and
in the way that she's got things
arranged right she's writing this
starting in 70s and 80s so not as much
has happened but the very first
interstellar probe is being launched in
2005 you know interstellar meaning going
way out there not just the the planet
into the interplanetary probes that we
have something that would go to a
different system we haven't done that
quite yet and between 2015 and 2125 she
is predicting the first manned
interstellar mission not just a
interplanetary mission not just say
going to Mars or going to where else
could we get to the asteroids can't
really go to Jupiter because we'd be
crushed and the storms there are crazy
but they they send out this ship to
Barnard star to build a station and and
much of the existence of humanity out
there in the cosmos is not like going
you know the way in the old space things
right you have a ship looks like a rock
at you Lana
planet you know shoot up the aliens or
maybe get along with them or something
and everything goes great no it's it's
much more like it is for us I mean we we
landed on the moon but we didn't stay
maybe we'll land on Mars in our lifetime
we'll see you know it depends on what
the priorities of our political systems
are but we do have space stations and
they last for a while and then you know
they start to break down you guys
remember when that that one came down
was that in the 1970s or early eighties
and everyone was worried it might crash
on that this is before you for years you
do well it's Kylie I think it was called
yeah so was it the eighties yeah
essentially yeah you know these things
have to go through iterations to and and
so when they become routine that's when
human beings can really spread out it's
not the the first the very first thing
that we do that's so cool that we have
all the fan for it fair for that that
matters it's really when it could become
a job that people just do because you
know it's better than mopping floors or
something like that that we'll know that
we've really made it and so they do this
with these creating these space stations
out there in different places and
meanwhile they're also sort of learning
how to mine asteroids and and you know
terraform Mars and do all those sorts of
things within the solar system but they
start sending out these these ships and
if we're gonna go to another now you
know another system rather than within
our system it's going to take a long
time and so they have these essentially
these colony ships where they're going
to have kids and those kids are have to
be raised on those ships
and then they'll go to where they're
going build something and then shoot it
back this way big risk I mean what if
something goes wrong you know they'll
never hear from them again right
but once they actually have a foothold
then they can expand that a bit more and
something very interesting happens along
this way they start discovering asteroid
extraterrestrial life but the human
beings that are going along on these
voyages they find out that they really
have much more in common with each other
than they do with their home
planet Earth it's very difficult to
relate to because think about you would
be gone for imagine if you were gone for
70 years from this culture that we live
in and how much has changed just in 70
years in our time could we adapt you
know this is actually one of the
problems that some of the guys that I
knew when I was teaching in the prison
faced where they had been behind the
walls there weren't anything like
furloughs or you know weekend passes
there's a maximum-security prison
they'd be in there for 25 years and
cellphones did get into the prison
through trafficking but they had very
little idea about what to do with them
they could see things on TV but you know
TV's not the reality that we live in and
then they would get out after 25 years
and there would be a massive culture
shock even though they had people coming
to visit them all right and talking
about what they were doing they lacked
some things to relate to it so imagine
being off on a voyage totally cut off
from Earth except for these
transmissions that would come in from
time and you can't make any sense of
them you you become in essence a new
culture and that's what what starts
handling and they start building more
and more stations wave further out and
some of them are actually by planets
that could be used so you notice they
talk about pail and down below station
down below is pal this is here you can
see the station there you know kind of a
not a great drawing there but you know
typical sci-fi stuff right and it's this
massive station where tens of thousands
of people live it can dock all these
different ships and down below there is
a planet that has a race of humanoids
already living there who turn out
fortunately to be you know very nice
gentle and they don't want to mess with
people and give them gifts and all that
because otherwise you know things would
have gone pretty bad and that planet
allows them to farm to you know develop
foodstuffs and things like that sigh
teen is another major world where that
happens as well so during all this time
Earth starts to go through a couple
major changes one of which is the
discovery of extraterrestrial life
throws a lot of people for a loop and
you can imagine like what would happen
to our culture today if that were to
happen I think there's probably a lot of
people who would have difficulties
finding a way to fit it into their their
religious points of view right so I
think we'd have some major religious
crises there probably would be some new
religions developing you know I think
some people would be like how can I make
a buck off of these aliens as quick as
possible
others would be like well we should wipe
them out you know and so it would lead
to a crisis and that's what happens on
earth
meanwhile in
economic you know realm there is a thing
the earth company starts to control a
lot of the things that are going on
within the solar system and outside of
Earth and so the the governmental
processes you know there's things like
the United Nations and all that but the
earth company comes to dominate you
could say right and now think about some
of the problems with not just logistics
but decision making so imagine like
you're you know 20 light years away and
you are as well and you're that far away
from her and I'm back on earth giving
you guys orders about what you ought to
do and you guys are supposed to report
to me every so often right and then
we'll make we'll make him like the the
enforcer you know he's got a spaceship
and if you guys don't do what I tell you
to do he'll fly out there of course it's
gonna take him 20 years to get there so
by that time you know he might have died
or you might have died or the situation
well there yeah and and you know the
orders saw you know by the time that I
actually get information from you about
what what conditions you're in and I
send you the orders the orders don't
make any sense at all so what would you
do in a case like that would you would
you like try to implement the orders
they're making sense for the situation
you know I mean it's evolved that you
can only take it to the point where it's
relevant if it's not the order said no I
mean if it is in the situation that
isn't going to be applicable to your
current you know yeah what's the point
that's right there there are some people
who are what we call you know they think
that they're following rules don't make
it work some all right yeah and they're
not likely this question does this make
sense of the current situation yeah and
some might be like these people don't
know what the hell they're talking about
screw them we're doing our own thing
alright and so you have that sort of
conflict brewing on these space stations
and on the few planets that are
inhabited waited part from Earth and the
company doesn't know what to do about
this and then two important things
happen one is they discover faster than
light travel and it gets discovered not
on earth but out in the colonies and
they start to use it so now all of the
the thing about it is it's sort of like
a map right although would have to be
like a three-dimensional map in space
and the coordinates would kind of move
around here and there but you could talk
about a star map and everything that you
know originally you had to go to this
place to get to this place to get to
this place
now you can bypass all that so it's sort
of like you know what we've experienced
here in the United States where you know
originally the the quickest mode of
travel around here canoes you know that
this whole area is littered with
waterways that the Explorer is used
you know Chicago itself is they thought
they found this out through not just
sort of doing anthropological studies
and archaeological things but you
actually look at imaging of it it was a
massive nexus of trade paths coming in
from from all over the place that the
Potawatomi had had kind of a little
stranglehold over and you know what
happens with that when something else
comes in like railroads all those old
modes of transport and all the ways of
life oriented around them they're at
risk of going away and then you know at
one time here in America we had a great
rail network you know I was talking with
the German guy today who's like your
rail network sucks and yeah and there's
a reason for that the you know our road
system and the American turned to the
automobile you know as part of why we
don't have great train transport like
they do in Europe and you know now we're
facing driverless cars and and
driverless semi and freight and stuff
like that within our lifetime again a
little bit of a hiatus because of that
one driverless car that ran over
somebody that that uber you know was
getting into it and then now it's sort
of on hold but it's not gonna say I'm
old for long and all of these
transformations change you know booming
areas into backwaters and they also step
up to the issue of well should we take
orders from these earth people who don't
know what the hell they're doing and
they just want to make a buck off of us
or should we go off on our own and some
of the world's some of the space
stations in effect rebelled they say
earth you're not in charge anymore and
they become what's called the Union and
at first the earth responds and I know
we're going over a lot of like back
history here before we get into actually
talking about what happens but so the
earth response is to say okay well
you're not going to obey well we're
gonna fix you as soon as Earth gets
faster than Mike
they start building this gigantic fleet
which is got 50 carriers in it and they
place it under this this captain mozzie
on who's you know like a tactical genius
and and all that and they send him out
to enforce order on these colonies that
have that have revolted and formed a
union unknown to them at the time that
Union solved a lot of their their own
problems one of the problems is manpower
earth is a you know long-standing planet
so there's tons and tons of people you
actually have too many people just like
we do today on earth so a lot of labor
force that you can use and out on the
colonies they don't really have that so
they start cloning people they start
labs in which you can make as many
people as you want you it still takes a
while to grow up right but you can make
them however you want and you can teach
them using what what she calls tape
which we could probably think of today
is sort of like some sort of induction
method where you would you would hear
things and they'd be structured in a
certain way so you'd learn very quickly
and you can manufacture people that's
that's what the Union starts doing at
all different like levels you know you
need some really smart ones those are
the ones that are called alphas
predictably enough right they go all the
way down to like these lower classes
named after Greek letters like ro
classes basically just good for sweeping
floors or you know carrying things
around and none of those clones actually
have legal rights they're bred for
certain purposes but they allow the
population to vastly increase and what
ends up happening
this fleet goes out there and things do
not turn out the way they expected they
start getting their proverbial butts
handed to the
even even though they're being run by
you know brilliant officers and they
have good discipline they're not they're
not easily beating the the Union as a
matter of fact the Union starts to beat
them and eventually the fleet winds up
turning to piracy and things like that
because earth is not supplying them with
the resources that they need and so now
you've got a couple different things
going on at the time that down below
station begins down below station pal
station is one of the bigger stations
and they are trying to remain neutral in
in what's going on between earth and
Earth's fleet which now by that time
only has a handful of their ships lost
these carriers and the Union who seems
to be advancing there's a lot of chaos
refugees start streaming in brought from
other stations and dumped on pail and
pail already it has kind of a delicate
balance going on between the different
people there and so they're caught in in
between long story short what ends up
happening is there's some fleet battles
there between the earth fleet and the
Union fleet and the merchants the people
who so far I haven't talked about at all
the people who make all the economic
stuff happen you know trading things
back you know from one world to the
other carrying cargo they don't want to
be ruled by earth and they don't want to
be ruled by Union they don't want to be
ruled by the fleet because the fleet is
always doing what military rulers tend
to do to tough civilians which is screw
them around and impress them meaning you
know make them part of their third
process and and treat them badly
so they actually end up performing their
own new system called the Alliance
that's why it's the Alliance union
universe the fleet rebels and except for
one fleet captain Mallory heads back to
earth to attack earth and trying to take
over Earth and Mallory stays behind
she defects from the fleet with her
carrier and that becomes the backbone of
the new alliance based in hell and
encompassing all these other stations
and all these these merchant vessels and
the merchant vessels the last thing that
I'll say about all this this development
so again imagine that you are living a
very different life than the life we
have here as terrestrial people right
imagine that you are gonna be on a ship
that jumps through space and time and
each one of those jumps requires that
you be drugged up because it's it's so
jarring to the body into the mind and
imagine that you are travelling either
from planet to planet or from way
station to plan it to new way station
over and over and over again and you may
hang out on those places you might like
go to drink and Gamble and sleep and eat
some real food or something like that
can't grow food on your ship but your
life is really those people on the ship
it's sort of like being in the military
or being in a company or something like
that but you never get to go home you're
living on that ship now imagine that
you're related to everybody on that ship
they're all your family and it could be
ten people or it could be like in the
case of merchants or Luck and Dublin
again it could be a thousand people a
thousand cousins
years right I don't know if any of you
come from really big clannish families
like mine is about 200 people and we
don't all get along and like each other
but you know can you imagine being
cooped up with them for four years but
they become very close and they become
each of them sort of like their own
little world you know you become very
oriented towards your family they do the
the women involved in those do go off
and sleep with people that they're not
related to so that the gene pool doesn't
get you know screwed up from inbreeding
but they don't form innate permanent
attachments those guys you know the
children stay with them and so the
answer the the merchant earth that's
what the the traders are doing so you've
got by the time that you know these
these books are going you've really got
a couple different major you could call
them factions or ways of living you have
the people within the the Union some of
whom are you know bred to be a certain
way you know to exist in just a certain
range of thoughts and desires and skills
and stuff like that
you've got the earth which is just a you
know messed up place nobody knows what's
going on there but earth is still you
know churning away
you've got the fleet the Maserati the
people who follow mozzie on and they're
still out there engaging in piracy and
doing their thing you've got the
Alliance which is based in Pell that
includes all these merchants and then
you've got all sorts of other free
agents doing their own thing and that's
the the the universe in which these
stories take place at least the ones
that don't involve aliens and I haven't
talked about aliens but I'm not and I'm
not going to say much about the aliens
because already it's it's too much isn't
it that's it
it's almost how do you how do we
describe this this is this is a massive
yeah exactly and you know one of the
things that she said that I jotted down
a few things from interviews and one of
the things she said about the Union
Alliance universe was that so that I
decided to set up a situation in which
there were no evil superpowers just
doing what superpowers do for their own
survival and to write stories from the
viewpoint of people on both sides and
that's that's what she I think really
does succeed in doing is creating a
universe in which the way that she tells
the story each of the characters you
know she gives you enough information
about them she tells you about what some
of the thoughts going on in their head
she develops them and and some of them
are pretty bad people but none of them
are totally been there there's nobody
who's like a psychopath in there who
just wants to destroy everything and
there's a lot of people who are pretty
good but none of them are like the good
guy the Savior the one person is going
to fix everything
and she looks at how their different
decisions or negotiations interface with
each other and I think that's very
interesting
I can imagine as a writer it must be
very difficult to pull off because I
think it's a lot easier just to write
you know the traditional space Western
you know the guys who have the black
hats and the guys who have the white
hats and haven't shoot each other with
blasters or you know the good guys are
because they've got the you know they
don't have the red light sabers they've
got the green and the blue ones or
things like that you know I think that's
a lot easier to write than this
so I've talked at you a lot this this
would be a good place to take a break in
you know any comments or questions
before I talk about some philosophical
themes you guys want to bring up some
philosophical themes yeah okay we're
it's basically it's basically like the
present time for where the show takes
place is I don't know where but it's
basically like Evil's space pressure
Empire versus space but like everything
leaving after that was like very similar
almost exactly like it was going up with
this so like percentile colony is the
colonies are Bell where it sends out
enforcers the enforcers actually managed
to basically beat everybody up okay but
eventually the person I was in charge of
that fleet becomes the king of the
universe basically yeah it turns on
earth yeah process yeah and then
basically takes over everything I mean
that is one of the the big problems with
having enforcers you know so here's
another thing to that that's quite
interesting so it's a chera she she
draws a lot on ancient history
and one of the things you see happening
over and over and over again in Roman
history is some emperor shoring up his
his regime by bringing in a general or
bringing in troops from outside and
they're gonna fix everything and he
always forgets that well once they
realize how weak you are they can turn
on you and take over and a lot of the
Roman emperors they were there was
actually a year of four Emperor's what
like in rapid succession they did that
and the other thing is - it destroys
legitimacy once you start monkeying
around with that well people take your
force seriously and they don't see you
as having you know any moral legitimacy
that would would make them willing to be
loyal to you or or fight for you they're
like well you got the best guns right
now so I guess I'd better you know pay
you my taxes but they're not gonna stick
with you right and so you see these same
so this is really interesting you see
the same human problems playing
themselves out because you can't get
away from the human condition just by
going to space oh yeah civilization is
spread out yeah yeah and you still the
same kind of games playing that people
do I mean in dune that's particularly
[Music]
there with like the harkonnens they will
always screw with everybody right you
can't imagine that like taking it easy
and not not going after the other the
other people we have people who are
target ensues focuses power yeah
you know the different human
characteristics we see yeah everything
yeah you know one of the things I do
like about her series - so like at the
start that the Alliance beat or the
Union people our portrayed is being kind
of scary you know they're doing all this
cloning stuff we don't know what's
happening way out there in these fire
stations we just know that they're like
beating the fleet and the fleet they've
turned into bad guys but these you know
these these Union people they might be
sort of like in Star Trek like the Borg
they're gonna assimilate you and you're
not gonna have any choices it's a very
you know sort of regimented way of life
and so to tell people are like well we
don't want that you know but when she
starts writing about the Union it turns
out that things are just as screwed up
there as they are anywhere else there's
just as many feuds and power struggles
and they have their own government which
is like split between a couple different
factions some of which really want to
push this you know like they're the
expansionist they're called and then
some want to
they're called isolationists and they
want to like just withdraw from earth
altogether and build their own new sort
of civilization and then there's the
moderates in the middle and you wouldn't
guess that like from the outside if
you're if you're in the one territory
you wouldn't look inside and see that
it's sort of like you know here here
today we often think of you know foreign
countries that we see as rivals is kind
of like monolithic right you know the
Chinese you know are great rivals but if
you if you get closer in you see while
China is just this massive panorama of
all these different people competing
cooperating misunderstanding each other
as well or we can think of other places
too even North Korea you know there's
got to be somebody with
later than the state all of these
writers it seems like you know even when
they take this way up into the future
they never conquer any evolution in the
human conditions Oh always the same
problems as always the same
circumstances nope nobody's gotten ever
beyond all of that like you're just a
political stuff yeah yeah the human
nature I mean did you just see it's
never transcended to grow into a higher
level it's always the same old thing
yeah whether you wanted 2,000 Sapir is
the writers never seem to grasp Clark
you know Clark Clark did but then that
that makes it less of an irritant well
there is something to that though I mean
with with South chera
there are some attempts to do something
that would like transform the situation
that way and you can see that what the
Union people are doing as representing a
new way forward for Humanity but then it
winds up usually not working that way
all right so they're gonna have they're
gonna like deal with the the the problem
of more of natality by just a little
tiff clones and then you got to figure
out what are we gonna do with all these
clones right and then people start
getting unscrupulous and how they're
handling them and and or they come up
with like the tape thing okay now
imagine wouldn't you like if we could
actually just like take a certain drug
and then listen to a tape or or whatever
some mp3 and we'd have all this
knowledge would it be cool but then who
creates the tapes and can you put some
liminal messages in and that's the sort
of question that she's so she's she does
have characters who are like or not just
characters but like
movements or people who are putting
something new forward but there's always
some fly in the ointment you know you
you you can never totally transform the
human nature towards towards some sort
of good in that way I mean think about
the technology of like the jump drive
which allows you to move from star
system to star system seems like a
neutral sort of thing but it could be
used to send an attack fleet to just you
know do a raid it could be used to
engage in trade it could be used to do a
diplomatic mission it really depends on
how you're your culture is developed it
doesn't it and I think we could say the
same about most other technologies and
this but the imagination isn't put into
transcending the human condition urban
nature's what I'm afraid to get is yeah
that yes it would not be as real
interval as now but it would be again
it's it's putting something that doesn't
exist presently as all of this does yeah
into what could be yeah and in the case
of a lot of her characters I'm just
thinking across the board with a lot of
science fiction writers they yeah theme
did they seem to go but they never took
actually you know the person it's always
the check or the or the son the world
something else but the person never
changes the individual person even like
people I'm talking about the feature
beyond the black rainbow it was the one
where they dipped the baby in the black
goop and the guy goes in - oh I haven't
seen that guys you see a lot you mean do
a lot of things I've never even heard of
you were so sick kind of resources look
at the Young Achiever vice versa - so
what happened with the so the lake I
think I think okay beyond the black
rainbow I think it's okay basically it
changes its it's either it's either he
changes human nature and that's doubt
relate to and like basically what he saw
when he got dipped into the black
changed him so much to the point where
he wasn't even human or it was something
about he saw things but then he
shouldn't have and his nature didn't
really change I yeah well you know so
they're I think there's two things to
say about Sheriff I think you see it you
see a chance to change human nature yeah
Clark Clark yeah
the Robins tried to set up Autopia yeah
and human nature exert itself oh yeah
and you see it in the dystopian fiction
like divergent where somebody's trying
to create a different kind of society
yeah those against the human nature
we've seen to transform it in some way
yeah and then it never works
yeah I mean with the you know you could
say like maybe there's something
fundamentally wrong with with with human
beings then and we did we didn't look at
100 author who had the aliens bring that
up as an as an issue with the genetic
modification and saying that the human
beings had a sort of interesting paradox
to them the one on the one hand they
were very intelligent on the other hand
they are hierarchical you put those two
things together you know blanking on her
name right now but uh-oh
Tavia mother yeah so you know that with
that one there's aliens that are then
the aliens don't have it all figured out
either but there are further advanced
that human beings are and they're like
we're going to try to you know we're
gonna give you the opportunity to like
work this crap out of your system
becomes when you make that change are we
so Jim are we still human yeah we make
that kind of change then do we stop
being human are we something else yeah
so you see that in Roma yeah well end in
childhood and childhood shall be death
yeah we can't relate to those those
children have become part of
mind and it's very sad but you know as
we first I mean we first started out
yeah we certainly are different now
yes I mean we're still human yeah and
we're not nearly as primitive as violent
and as everything else so why is it in
the future we can not evolve into
something a little bit better and
because we have been getting better yeah
but what I'm seeing is normally I'll be
beating this dead horse it probably I
just think this is a very important
philosophical question that science
fiction writers generally do not take as
they take everything else into the
future they don't take humans because
that we do we are evolving we're not the
people we were you know twenty thirty
fifty six hundred thousand years ago we
were seeing violence today but that's
the thing there is still once and so
there's a cumulative process so I think
that I think that's right actually chera
had something interesting to say about
about that she said having made a
thorough study of the past I'm certain
that I do not wish to live in it nor do
I wish to see three quarters of the
planet weltering and conditions that
should have been left in the past with
the same hunger and disease or ancestors
knew the reach for space and its
resources is the make-or-break point for
our species and the appropriate use of
technology and the adjustment of human
viewpoint to a universe not limited to a
blue sky overhead and the curvature of
the horizon are critical to our survival
therefore I write fiction about space
and human adjustment to the unfamiliar
yeah okay
I think though so to go to the lot of
the characters are you might say stuck
in situations where they would like they
would like to do something different
they would like to be better people they
would like to be more charitable or just
or something like that
but because of the the way like the
economic situation that they're stuck in
there like why can't do that because
I'll be screwed you know I won't be able
to make my my profit margin or these
people will take advantage of me and
it's sort of like there's always so much
of the past of the ways that we've done
things before that gets kind of brought
along like d'être chests well yeah yeah
so and and so the alternative to that is
like let's wipe it all clean and
sometimes you can do that but it's
pretty rare that you get an opportunity
to do that most of us are stuck dealing
with the stupid cobbled together stuff
and if we can be good people it's it's
like in just in this little way not in
some sweeping across the board way so I
mean like one locus for that is like how
people live in terms of their their
family how they bring up their kids or
like in this this one merchant there's
luck you got this guy it's it starts out
as a love story but it turns out he's
actually dealing with you know all these
sort of ghosts from his past on the ship
where his family was killed by the
Maserati and the woman who he pursues at
the start by the end of it they're not
lovers
they're like partners on you know
commercial venture but they're but
they're part of something the other
thing I was going to say too is so one
I'd say one theme that doesn't really
come up with this is a question that
you're raising and it's like you could
say who decides for humanity what
humanity is going to look like in the
future should it should it be you know
we'll do more the same old [ __ ] from
the past just you know their different
faces different names that seems to me
when Earth is doing or should we you
know in some some radical way reshape
humanity and and I think that's part of
what the Union people are doing with
their their clones and tape you know
sort of mind not mind washing but for
implanting all these things well I mean
they they try to spread out to the other
stars and then they they meet alien
species and I think that's another thing
too for chera and this isn't really
within the scope of these books although
there is you know there is that one
alien species that's on the planet in
this case through encountering the alien
and not like shooting it or you know
turning it into slaves or running away
just in fear from it were offered a
possibility for further human
development in her works I'd say and
different characters choose different
things like some guys are the guys are
the alien let's shoot it you know now
that goes maybe maybe what we actually
do need this is highly speculative but
maybe what what we do need is in order
to evolve as humans further is something
that's not human
for us to relate to and maybe it
wouldn't necessarily have to be alien
life like going off to another planet
like if we could really figure out
what's going on with elephants or higher
Apes or dolphins maybe that would lead
us to see things in a broader way that
would allow us as as human beings to
well that was the Octavia Butler's
notice to have transformed notice to it
that one they show up because we've like
had a nuclear war in the meantime they
were also giving some reward so yes you
know another thing that they do with
technology is they figure out using that
venture that cloning stuff how to
replicate animals from DNA so they get
DNA from animals on earth then they ship
it out to the stars and then you know
you've got a planet okay we could we
could make some fish there you know and
have bass or bluegill or whatever
whatever it is that we want yeah yeah
we're used to probably they have other
stuff but they go ahead I wonder if this
exemptions visas I know I know also I
can say like yeah that's pretty I mean
maybe maybe you can I mean if you stuff
tissue samples but we don't have the
technology to do that this time they're
truly extinct you don't issue samples
alone there's at cloning is absolutely
without oh yeah yeah to retain tissue
samples yeah well I mean extinct just
means that all the living examples of
that kind that's probably true you know
we've got things that are frozen yeah I
mean if you want to dig up a mammoth and
you we're not gonna clone I mean that
just wouldn't make any sense
and plus the guys are dug it up made the
dang thing yeah another another thing
that that I think that's really
interesting in her words is the
adaptation that human beings have to
have to space you know like we feel a
lot of sci-fi shows where you know I
think about Star Trek for example or the
Star Wars universe is even worse this
way all ships have an artificial gravity
you know everybody knows where up is and
traveling in space for years and years
doesn't really have any adverse effects
you just go to the gym you know take the
space shots or pills and you're fine
right but as it turns out you know the
human body is not really made to operate
in zero-g condition
yeah and so she she spends a lot of time
not in these books so much but in other
ones like in heavy time what heavy time
is is the time that you're no longer
weightless from you know being a miner
out there in space and your rig mining
asteroids and you go there and it's on a
space station that has you know
centrifugal force because of the
rotation and you have to decide what
deck you're gonna be on if you want to
file your claims it's all on the heavy
gravity deck so they make you like go
through this essentially gauntlet and
the weight what you have to do is a
human being in order to survive that his
workout in the gym
before you actually get there your gym
in your ship so that your bones don't
get too brittle and your muscles don't
atrophy and then while you're on the
ship during your time you need to like
be exercising or else your body's gonna
break down and then you know there's
there's other things that can go wrong
with it as well and she's you know she
does a really great job and sort of like
thinking through what would it take for
this human body that we have to be able
to survive out there in the merciless
void of space all the different
fail-safes that could fail you know
really again if I had read this when I
was in my 20s I think I would have found
it mind-boggling we boring you know but
reading it it's an older guy I like wow
there's there's so much thought in this
and you know the other thing I'll say
that's a little bit related to this she
does a lot of setting things up with all
these different characters and plots
happening and usually it's about like
the two third mark I've observed where
everything starts to you know fall into
place and now everything happens very
quickly and then some sort of new
resolution happens but until then it's
kind of slow going
there was there was one other thing that
I particularly wanted to remark on - but
do you guys have any other ones that you
want to bring up or hit on or we don't
but that was a great observation about
the human evolution thank you that's
okay if not one of the things that I
wanted to talk about is the the role of
female characters she actually was asked
about this and she said my goal is to
create characters that men can identify
with just the same as women identified
with the male heroes everybody wants to
be a hero in what they're reading and
like you know the greatest military hero
she has in this is Mallory the the
captain of the Norway this is who makes
the difficult decision to betray her
admiral who is betraying earth and then
to help form the alliance and she's hard
as nails you know and actually there's a
couple other female characters in there
who are like that as well and one
essayist in a book called the dreams or
stuff is made of said that the success
of chairs books is owned in part two
other authors coming before her who had
this strategy of hypothesizing women's
who can cope in a man's world rather
than aslha queen would have a remodeling
human nature on a maternal template so
Shara and other women writers of her
time from like the 70s onward they they
deal with the gender issue in large part
not by saying well you know men and
women you know the proverbial
Mars and Venus sort of thing they say no
you can have very Venus like men you can
very mars-like women and everything in
between
it doesn't really you know play out that
that these things are just tied in with
particular genders I'm not saying I'm
not knocking the Greens approach which
is to you know sort of postulate
alternate ways of being why not have
three sexes why not have all these
different possibilities but I think this
is this is something that actually works
and you see it you know it took a while
for that to catch on in the sci-fi
universe if you think I got about TV
shows right
think about Star Trek took quite a while
before we had Voyager
you know first we had the original Star
Trek with hyper-masculine Kirk that we
all make fun of now you know this karate
chops and that's right that was the
original pilot and the network's at ya
know can I have a female second officer
and then even with like you know the new
generation okay you got the card all
right very different than Kirk but you
know exactly then you got Riker who's
basically Kirk only one why D you know
as well and you do have more female
characters in there so it's not just her
yeah exactly
yeah well you get crush her and you've
got Troy and who else everybody else
yeah they killed off the the female like
some dirty chief right up and right at
the start you know what's a diamond
she's the bartender that's true yeah
yeah and then you know then things start
to change and you get you know an actual
female captain you know or you can have
a female head of security and they and
you know it changes things so much for
me it's like you know it's kind of a
relief to have these possibilities
because it putting people into boxes
like that that's true yeah the society
slowly changing or the society as is at
the time yeah yeah written when Shara
was writing some of these books was at a
time when if you wanted to succeed in
business as a woman you acted like a man
yeah so to be a head of a department or
to be a well I think that's still very
much the case yeah look at that time in
the 70s and 80s
yeah for women to achieve they had to be
tough hard as nails yeah well they were
given the same they're acting like the
same as the male ones but they were seem
different but they have--they like
overreaction you do everything twice as
hard so I mean it's interesting thing
about with these these are not that far
in the future narrative Lee right there
like say two hundred years from now
three hundred years from now so if we've
seen this much change in our lifetime
what is it going to be like in terms of
gender unless there's backtracking in
terms of gender relations that would be
like five too you know
teen generations from now will that no
longer be much of an issue right now
you're seeing backlash against
activities yes not sure that not just
here to not just say about India you
know oh yeah
the the Mormon Church just issued a
mandate to their women find it what is
that there they are too fast from all
social media oh that's true because
social media is contaminating the minute
well there's a later even reach back in
terms of you know that's trying to
regain control that is a really
interesting way you think of how
prevalent social media is in so many
people's lives you know and for a lot of
people if they're kind of isolated
social media gives you a support network
you know but the Mormon Church just made
that you know yesterday that declaration
interesting a denomination with no
central theology is clear a little Eric
you too we have a Harvey my
understanding that it's kind of like
each church has like some variation well
they have a main theology yeah they have
a main theology series for very strong
very structured there are there are some
smaller latter-day saints churches yeah
that are much much less centralized and
they're the second largest one is much
more
liberal but the main ones are very
conservative and they you know they do
have a sort of top-down hierarchy with
overseers and things like that but I
mean you can say the same about many
other religious organizations as well
and it'll be interesting you know to see
how they how they're able to adapt if
they do what do you think it's in
response to light all the response
because because during the cabinet
comfort confirmation hearings a whole
bunch in terms of reporting seminar but
they were letter in terms of women and
paying attention to what women had to
say ah okay and it was a whole bunch of
Mormon women yeah and I mean it's
interesting this is a really far off
track with respect to the shara thing
but with with the you know current
Republican sort of makeup and so
dominated by Trump the one normally like
very faithful Republican religious group
that he didn't succeed with was the
Latter day Saints and parkas he dissed
Romney and in part because they had
their own candidate McMullen it was
rotting in Utah's non-trump guy yeah and
and so I think they're kind of an
interesting group in the current
political situation because most other
conservative let's call them
constituencies have lined up almost in
lockstep behind the Trump administration
ones that you would have thought they
would have
exactly yeah our country it's not just
yeah we've seen the nationalist parties
across the globe and it's it's that we
don't want progress we don't want
diversity we don't want fear and
backlash we don't women irritate for
thousands of thousands of years there's
and things are starting to equal nice a
little bit there's so much fear with
males and they don't even they see this
to take over Britain and the partnership
and say yeah get over well that's not
really humanistic get over it a human
nature thing to see it as a zero-sum
game yeah it's I think it's human nature
I don't I think there's a thing with
humans this is the spaceship this goes
to that evolution thing though and you
know some of the people that I work on
had they looked at that that precise
thing like like if you think about
Rainer Maria Rilke or Mary
Wollstonecraft they both looked at the
issue of you know male-female relations
has screwed up by being a zero-sum game
where if one if one group wins the other
group loses and both of them made the
case that in a certain way both sexes
are being stunted by that that now women
usually have suffered much more because
of that and when there was one of wool
storms Wollstonecraft's points but she
also points that were mend wind up you
know sort of imposing these ridiculous
demands upon themselves and and nobody
ends up being happy as as a result
political parties and yeah because if
you hear people on the left saying oh
well they're dying out anyway well the
demographic I mean if you just take the
braids I mean men are you know total
agency you put them on your MRI and you
say where do you want it where do you
want to go for lunch a B pizza something
like where do you want to go for lunch
the whole prefrontal cortex long ago
nothing but possibilities yeah so what
you need so the brains were meant to
work in cancer but the woman there's too
much possibility so they need the agency
of the male's to really tell but you you
need both yeah just need both and this
is why it was so when you're when you're
completely in here meeting a whole hyper
population you're leaving out all of the
possibilities yeah and the progress and
they thinks the imagination you can use
decides like you need like a third you
almost need like a third party to
coordinate the two other parties but
where are you going to get that third
party it's going to come from you know
what yeah or or maybe if you could have
some you know maybe it takes having
models of people living there it's
getting there the younger generations
are figuring it out they're getting
there some people are on some of the
words I mean it's it's interesting
because the there's also like a big rise
in people who are just like opting out
of dating and sexuality altogether
where they're like screwed you know this
is nice all the time he's 29
yeah and she's so frustrated with her
generation really because she sees them
sliding backwards to traditional gender
roles on traditional gender roles and
and women who you take you make the
decisions and she's watching that around
her
getting really frustrated with women her
age well I guess I guess say no I
haven't seen I'm not me happy I'm gonna
see the life yeah that's kinda not
standing up no I'm not taking that no
not having a home you know I again my
view is very very just you know tiny
little section but I don't see that with
my students much you know it seems like
on the whole my female students
typically are doing better than my male
students less you know not getting
things done on time are they you know
they more consistently contributed class
and that therefore get better
participation grades and other there's
there's plenty of men who are doing fine
that there's there seem to be a lot that
are just kind of like dropping through
the cracks some women too but it seems
like there's and they do seem to
exercise more control over their their
lives you know I like to see it myself
because I want to see everybody do well
but I think if someone was a member of
that generation guys talking about
yeah it's if you need to consider
I guess the status of just waiting for
someone to die there are things like
that basically people in my generation
are asked to clean up all the crap I
glass I'm not saying 21 I'm saying like
the last 200 you're right starting with
like even like like Napoleon days right
basically everything's going that it's
not just like the sexual things it's not
just like like economic things it's not
just overpopulation things it's not just
oil things it's not just technology
things it's not just we're gonna get off
this planet things it's not just global
warming things it's not just rights
things it's not just racial things it's
not job it's it's it's it's it's not to
say that you shouldn't like I'm still
trying to figure out my full opinion on
this but I I think to say that
saying I'm not going to deal with all of
these things is the healthiest option
for most people my age because there's
overwhelming right it's there's so much
it I wouldn't say it's too much for
somebody to go through but it's too much
too fast
well tea process yeah and changing world
views takes in an enormous amount of
energy into like basically it's it's
gonna take a little bit more time I
think I think I'm really interested in
seeing what people like five to ten
years younger than I am so basically
somewhere a bit between the ages of 14
and 19 because I think they will be able
to digest everything that well we kind
of see I mean I would say like
Millennials house for 1994 like I would
say Millennials kind of salad kind of
how like the previous like 10 years
older kind of my generation Generation X
yeah yeah I kind of like kind of got to
groove with some stuff but kind of saw
some things going forward and people
individuals react in their own way or
like them same as any other numeration
but like I'm really basically like the
generation that's like 5 or 10 years
younger than me has had time to like
digest and kind of girl grew up with the
world is where it's at I think I guess
going back to like the ties of like how
much like not just traditional but just
like how much baggage can old times
bring I think there's definitely
as far as like just specifically
technologies between the simmons five or
ten years younger than me because they
technology is much more of a guest
presence part you know I guess the idea
of someone five to ten years younger is
lifestyle than me I mean but I mean at
the same time you could say the same
thing for like anybody at the stable
like I've never seen a world without
political dysfunction when you construe
this you you have come into a world a
different world you know like you know
she and I are the older end of this yeah
he yes I mean you know what we have we
have a good representation of
generations here and I and I said you
and you have you you just you you really
have not seen anything but dysfunction
and and other kind of things tonight and
I say this often time you know to my
daughter and to little grandkids that
you know I I said I'm really sorry we
really effed up the world this bad for
you guys that you don't even have that
it's almost a hopeless situation that's
so many young people are choosing not to
have children as so many other things
because they don't see any you know and
you know was the massive consumption are
the Boomers of the consumption of the
boomers that got us here and that got us
to this stage of greed and and as part
of it I think yeah I mean I feel bad I
would count object to say that it's a
generational fault
that is totally asinine I mean I know
people I have friends with piss and moan
about boomers like it's none of the
tomorrow and I know plenty all the Jets
kill play but every see exactly
but is the old guards kind of dying out
like like a lot of racism is dying off
because like my parents I mean yikes
all right that generation is just about
gone and that's better generation when
it's gone it'll be better but when you
look at the white supremacist groups
small they have people older but you're
always gonna have that but you know that
better yeah there has been a lot of
progress yeah there's there's pockets
now where it's so much whereas I mean
you think about just like the casual use
of the n-word like in the area that
we're currently speaking in right and
residing in this is Brookfield you know
20 30 years ago people do throwing
around like that and only worrying if
they actually saw a black person you
know then they might turn it down but
now I think there's a lot of people
would be like some of the some gonna be
you know wanting to use it and you know
complaining that they don't get to use
it and then there's plenty who would be
like why would I why would I ever talk
that way you know and so there has been
some progress at least yeah so say
Chicago oh yeah and I mean you been on
Maxwell Street on Sunday after Saturday
afternoon and my dad was saying with you
know there's nothing but in the Jews I
mean yeah and and and that's how I got
the Blues infused into my bloodstream
that'll never leave because I'm probably
lose I'm listening to like you know the
guys coming up
migration great you know my grandparents
generation in Chicago
everything was so essentially catified
ethnic absolutely that if somebody came
into your neighborhood whether you'd
beat him up yeah you did that's way my
mom and I didn't go to the Polish
neighborhoods you didn't we don't go to
the Italian did could not go to the
Polish and certain things like no Irish
I mean you absolutely knew you had your
little segment of Europe and that was an
element say it was it's awful it was
probably like that in Milwaukee
yeah it was I mean still is growing up
that's all I ever learned
yeah you just played in some areas you
still have some of that there's I mean
not to the point where people are
getting beat up yeah on the south side
oh poor Rican neighborhood Colombian
neighborhood the Honduras neighborhood
okay yeah we do have some minutes to
when I was 14 and you have it was too
much of luggage shop it can be system of
it yeah I saw those Southside polish men
standing there with those signs and we
came up when we were marching with brat
before publishing rights
I saw what anger and rage look like in
those men I was 14 years old that I was
you know something really interesting to
go back to share that happens in down
below station I mentioned they're like
refugees right and and she so this is
coming out yeah so you know that's long
before we had any sort of refugee crisis
like the one that we're seeing in Europe
currently and to a lesser extent here
yeah I guess we didn't have some of that
going on but not huge right now yeah
well now it is but we do have some you
know we had that we have the boat people
but but it wasn't it wasn't as they're
willing to worry that like refugees are
gonna swap our culture and that's part
of what happens in down below station
these are all people from other stations
who are brought by the fleet and they're
just dumped there and they're told a pal
you got to take care of these people so
they created an area called queue
quarantine where all these people are
just stuck half of them don't have
papers nobody knows what's one gangs
start running it and you can see a
similar concern to what again lesson not
quite as big of an issue for for us as
it is in Europe right now but they've
been thinking about it for no bit longer
than we have but but she's she's already
you know approaching that kind of issue
and think about how would people deal
with it and what are the dangers you
know when the mob in queue gets sort of
riled up and used by you know the
foreign agent from the Union they wind
up you know knocking a lot of stuff down
and killing some people and the fleet
has to come in and shoot people and
click charge and it's a terrible
situation all around
you know she's got some interesting
discussions of mob mentality in there
generalisation yeah exactly we create
detention centers and camps when you
create those isolated communities yeah
then within within them you generate
some other things you know that and
that's another thing that's quite
interesting so in Western societies you
know we we do this Australia does this
it happens in Europe as well you know we
have got this like we you know we should
only punish people with with prison if
they've been convicted of a crime right
and yet when it comes to handling
detention for Refugees and also when it
comes in certain areas to doing jail we
hold people for sometimes years without
giving them any sort of due process and
there's you know at least if you're in
prison a lot of prisons are pretty bad
but at least if you're in prison there's
some sort of oversight right but a lot
of these detention centers not just for
us but like Australia is a major issue
to nobody you people go in nobody
follows up you know there's natural for
them to create their own society yeah
power structures and then we have things
too like in Chicago with like you know
the places where the cops would take
people before booking and they just
disappear yeah forget it is like a
renditioning but I'm trying to think
were they were they yeah you know there
was a there's a philosopher who talks
quite a bit about this his name is
Giorgio Agamben
he's an Italian guy pretty old and he
makes a distinction he's been writing
about this for you know a couple decades
he makes a distinction between you know
like a life that's recognized as
belonging within a system and then what
he calls bear life where you've got a
human being and he or she is just that's
it they're they're alive their body and
they don't have any sort of rights or if
they do the rights are just granted by
the people in authority and they're not
they're not really recognized that he
said this is a real problem because this
is going to happen more and more and
more and I think you see that happening
and being discussed in these these books
and you see that as a an issue with
detention centers or things like that
today you know or people who are afraid
to come forward because they're
undocumented you know rights yeah yeah
you know I kind of wish that here I'm
totally editorializing
I can't wish we're less obsessed with
like voting isn't right and we're more
like other modern countries where it's a
duty and everybody just votes and if you
don't vote you get a fine you know I
mean yeah I mean this isn't a silly that
we like we create all these bars to
being able to participate whereas in
most places are like listen you don't
want to participate you're going to pay
especially to younger people that goes
back to the other issue though so yeah I
mean you're you're right your generation
is going to be stuck unfortunately
dealing with all these problems and it's
kind of do-or-die time and the question
is how they're at how your generation is
actually going to get the agency you
know people like taking their hands off
and letting them do things you know
I can only say yeah I think I think to a
certain extent there is a lot of fear
but even more so for a lot of people and
I I think you know I'm seeing this just
based off what I've seen I think this is
especially true for men it's a lot of
men don't having patience I think this
is especially true for men but this is
also true for many women it will submit
my age is that a lot of people don't
really see a reason to care about what's
going to be coming there's not there's
not really it's like existential it's
just like a loss of hope or like despair
or it's maybe maybe I don't know it's
like I mean I I feel personally certain
elements of that within my own life I
mean I think everybody does but like
yeah it's specifically looking forward
with like what's going on in the world
and like where do I belong I I think I
think the reaction I think for a lot of
people who's whoa pretty much what I'm
saying is I don't know I think that's I
think I think that can be a right
response for a lot of people but also
like that is an existential issue and
it's sort of like you're being called
upon to do two things at the same time
which is figure out who you are and how
to fix things and maybe maybe that's too
much to ask of a lot of people where do
you desire is like yeah
this is that kind of vision at this
point a lot of a lot of the present
institutional structures are breaking
down yeah let's say are they are
completely not really breaking down and
I think we're seeing that yeah and
that's why all of this this for your
agent and steps going out because we
leave wasting them but what I see with
this young group and when that's gone
and it probably will at some point
collapse but what I see when I hope for
people coming up who have been so
immersed in in community whether it's
social media or anything else that
things will rise up from s community
look from from the bottom and then
they'll have actually demos in this
country and it won't be just as
hierarchical come down it'll be small
community why things because and rule
bill will be more like community rule
because you have more ideas out of 35
people and you get out of one you know
and and that's how I see the future
possibility possibly building back up
and that is a lot to throw on somebody
but like I said that you might introduce
at your generation but it might be
coming up from the people right kids
right now who are that who are just
coming into their own I could see work
generally speaking I would say with a
large degree of confidence I'm not very
confident in I'm not 100% confident that
I believe this and a lot of my own
opinions but like this one I feel pretty
strong enough is that American
Millennials do not respect other
people's points of view are not
- being that I have to see that for all
those electrons that being said I don't
think that the future is going to be uh
no authoritarian that's my point of view
just based off of like what I see not
only not necessarily what people act
like but like what people will say what
they want
I'm not sure over there that they want
authoritarian because they just don't
want to be responsible over stuff there
is so much that needs the attention paid
to that it's like somebody else made the
decision yeah and you know so this is a
good place to close you know a lot of
the stuff that's happening this is sort
of thing called technocratic right
there's there's a whoever's whoever
controls the not just the technology
itself but the processes whoever Roblin
the rule books and stuff like that they
get them to assign because they can
manage things and maybe that's that's
[Music]